excellent hi everyone thank you for
choosing to spend the next hour with me
my name's Adam I work for a company
called particular software we're the
makers of a product called end service
bus has anyone heard of any service bus
at all that's about half of you I am
going to show you a little bit a few
things to do with that in this talk but
that's not the point here
um I'm going to talk about
a certain class of problems which not
many people actually talk about that
often it's to do with the runtime
behavior of your code you might say well
I do think about the runtime behavior of
my code when I write it and that's true
but there are a certain class of
problems which only really manifest
themselves at runtime they may be quite
difficult to predict beforehand and in
particular I'm going to talk about the
hour of time so the error of time is a
term coined by a guide called Sir Arthur
Stanley Eddington and he said the time
when it moves in One Direction you can't
predict the future and of course you
can't I'm not going to try and predict
the future
but we can kind of fold things that need
to happen in the future into our current
code now I'm going to sort of take a few
ideas you may have seen and kind of
invert them and turn them upside down
and tear them apart I expect that to
raise questions so I don't know if I
will have time for Q a during this
session and actually it's lunch right
after this right so I'll try and let you
out a few minutes early to get ahead of
the queue uh but I will be at the
particular software booth just outside
in the hall uh throughout the whole of
lunch and most of the rest of the
conference so please do not hesitate to
come and grab me and ask me about this
stuff I love talking about it
so I'm going to take a fairly effeminate
familiar example I I guess you've all
probably seen Amazon at one point or
something similar to it so it doesn't
need much much explanation it's an
e-commerce site but the thing is if you
are in this kind of area of business and
you are running some kind of e-commerce
site first of all you are up against
Amazon and you're up against a whole
load of other people and you need to try
and differentiate so I'm going to take a
very simple case the business might come
to you and say
you know what we're going to try and uh
give customers discounts so something
like just to keep it simple if a
customer orders more than 100 pounds
worth of goods within a week we're going
to give them a 10 discount okay fairly
simple so you think all right great I am
going to use domain driven design and
we're going to use object orientation
I'm going to use event driven
architecture and all the rest of it I'm
going to make this nicely encapsulated
use all the techniques I've heard about
uh just like I've tried to use all the
animation techniques in this slide and
you come up with some nice tested code
and some nice object trying to code and
it's all nice we're not doing anything
particularly fantastically complicated
here we're taking the so when we submit
this order right we're going to take all
the orders where the customer ID equals
this orders customer ID okay so all the
orders for the current customer
we're going to look at all the orders
which are which have a time set greater
or equal than now minus seven days okay
so in the last week we're going to Total
those up and if the week total is
greater or equal to 100 pounds we're
going to give a 10 discount otherwise
zero
great right and then we do other stuff
to actually process the order
looks fine right so that goes into
production and it seems to work what's
the problem
now I did say
um okay you you might say well you know
this is a big query on possibly like a
massive database table or something so
you might kind of slow the database down
and stuff like that but you can optimize
that work with your dbas get indexes
create and all the rest of it
um there's another problem though
remember I said
customer
so that can be an account for a company
user is not necessarily customer or
account there can be two users within
that company there could be a hundred
users within that company
two people may click the button at the
same time
let's say that they've been ordering
things for 10 pounds each and I've made
nine orders right they're going to see
some a sum of
that word wrapping is unfortunate but
the sum is 90 right they're going to say
the sum of the current orders is 90.
what discount level are they going to
give
it's less than 100 we're going to get a
discount level of zero
so both of these orders get discounted
at zero the bill comes at the end of the
month and the person paying the bill has
a look and says hang on a minute hang on
a minute we've made 11 orders in this
week at the beginning of the month why
didn't that 11th order get discounted
and if kind of scratching your head and
they say well we did
um we did release that code we did
release that feature into the system you
should have got the discount so you go
to your logs and you're kind of trawling
through and you're working out and then
you realize oh hang on hang on a minute
they just happened at the same time you
clicked at the same time can you can you
just wait a few minutes before clicking
that second order
a customer looks at you and says what
how am I supposed to do that I've got
100 people in this office and they're
all ordering I don't know when they're
ordering they say well I don't know hold
up a sign to say that I'm ordering when
you're ordering it the customer says you
know that's ridiculous um I think I
might just go to Amazon instead has
anyone heard of the term death by Amazon
right if you don't run your business
efficiently and well enough that's what
tends to happen and Amazon tends to eat
you
and then you think okay well I know I
can do this right the answer is obvious
transactions right we're going to wrap
this in a transaction
so we're going to put these things into
transactions and make sure the read
can't read something which hasn't been
updated by the other transaction etc etc
the problem is that the fault the
default transactional level in say SQL
Server is recommitted so they are still
going to see the 90s so you're saying
okay I need to make that serializable
um don't forget we're doing big queries
across a big table here and you roll
that into production and all of a sudden
your error logs start to fill up and
it's like oh my god what have we done
like quickly roll that back
because you're getting dead locks and
that kind of stuff
and what you need to realize though is
that those error logs are telling you
something they're telling you that
you've got a highly concurrent system
here you've got lots of users ordering
at the same time that's great right good
business well done marketing but you've
got concurrency problems you need to
figure out a way to solve it
so you think okay another thing I've
done in the past is I've used a batch
job
so you might write some code like this
to say
we're going to look through the
customers
for each customer we're going to do a
very similar thing to what we saw before
we're going to say grab all the orders
where the customer ID equals this
Customs ID where the orders in the last
week sum them up if the value if the sum
is greater or equals 100 pounds discount
10 otherwise discount zero right great
and you update the customer table with
that saying this customer's discount is
zero
that tends to work quite well
um although there is one glaring problem
with it but before I go into that I will
say that if you're lucky you get to
write this in C sharp
but I'll give you a tip don't ever let
your DBA see it
because when I made that mistake they
rewrote it for me right I've got this
nice stuff with my nice c-sharp classes
encapsulating the database they replaced
it with a SQL statement
and they gave me a stored proc and said
nope you're running this instead
and this is actually quite quite hard to
argue with because this is almost
certainly with all the tuning they can
do and all the query hints and all the
indexes they can do this is almost
certainly going to run better than your
c-sharp
and they'll very often give you the
first version of stored proc and say
that's yours now go and look after it
now What's Happening Here is that the
business like this because it works it's
very efficient and then all of a sudden
another one appears
and this is just random SQL I copied
from the internet just I don't even know
what it does and then another one
appears and another one appears and
what's Happening Here is
anyone heard of the Strangler pattern I
think that might be in the gang of four
that's about half of you
um Stang the pattern very briefly is
where you take a really nasty piece of
code and you kind of carve out bits of
it one by one replace it with a nice
code until that bit in the mill is kind
of strangled out of existence this is
almost like a kind of reverse Strangler
pattern because what happens is all that
nice DDD and tdd code that you wrote in
here is kind of shrinking in importance
the interesting stuff the new
requirements the differentiators that
the business have come to you with are
all out here right this is becoming the
system
and a talk from personal experience
because I've laying awake at night
wondering how I'm going to debug that
stored proc tomorrow
you know it's very very difficult to
test these in the same way that you can
test this kind of stuff in the middle
here and sooner or later I realized that
I had a big ball of mud right I just had
this little thing in the Middle with all
these stored procs bolted on the outside
doing all the interesting business work
and it was very hard to kind of think
about
so what we need is but the thing is even
even if you manage to avoid that problem
and you manage to keep it in C sharp
you've got one very obvious problem here
this runs overnight for example it might
run a bit more often but it runs some
certain set period doesn't continuously
run
if it runs overnight what you're doing
is you're no longer penalizing users for
clicking on at the same time you're
penalizing for cleaning on the same day
so you've taken a race condition
effectively expanded it to an entire day
so you kind of say to the user well you
know do 10 orders wait till tomorrow for
the 11th okay okay I'm off to Amazon
it doesn't really work too well
so you could do things like
retroactively apply discounts you know
you could say okay well what orders did
you do in the meantime and kind of
retroactively give the money back so you
see your child your car getting charged
and then reading and then credit it
again it's just weird it's just not as
good as the way Amazon does it so we
need to think about something else
um
we need to think about this hour of time
again and what it actually means so
let's have a look at it this is the hour
of time
as orders come in obviously we process
them and we store them in the database
now
the business has said to you when an
order comes in
I want you to look at all the orders for
the last week
add them up
if the total is greater than or equal to
100 give a discount of 10 otherwise zero
the thing is that that is not a
requirement that is a work around
the user has just given you a workaround
within the constraints of their
knowledge of the current system
a requirement is
when an order comes in
if the customer has spent more than 100
pounds in that week give them a discount
of 10.
that might seem like a subtle change in
wording but we've gotten rid of that you
must look back in time you must sum up
the orders blah blah blah blah they're
not talking in terms of the system
anymore they're talking in terms of the
pure business requirement Now by getting
rid of that look through the previous
orders we've freed ourselves up to do
something else
let's have another look the hour of time
again
when the first order comes in what's the
current week total
zero exactly the current week total is
zero so we process that order we look at
the week total it's zero we process that
order at the discount level of zero then
we add
the current orders total to the current
week total and we store it in the
database
we then send ourselves a message one
week into the future to say in one week
take away this orders total from the
week total
so you can see for the duration of that
week that orders total is going to be in
there right that that that week total is
going to be correct for that one week
when the second order comes in we do the
same thing we add the second orders
total to the week total and a week from
then we take away the second orders
total from the week total right we send
ourselves a message to do that
and then we take away the the total and
then the same with uh third message
which is exactly the same thing again
and you can see what we've got now is
this sliding window right at any point
in time we've got the sliding window of
what is the orders what is the total for
that customer for the past week in that
one number right the week total
when an order comes in and so are so
forth and so forth and so forth when a
given order comes in what do we do
we look back at the history do we look
back through the table and scan it and
try and find out what what does we need
to take into account no we do not we
retrieve a single Row from the database
a weak total
that's great and equal to 100 with a
discount of 10 otherwise zero
so what we're doing is so anyone here
into DDD
does anyone like DDD that's quite a few
of you so if you that in that case this
is right up your street right you know
the whole thing about ubiquitous
language you've just sent this has just
entered your ubiquitous language right a
week total and you can see it in your
code right you're writing code in terms
of that ubiquitous language right you're
getting deeper insights
so we're folding the history into our
current state in a currently highly
consistent way you can almost think of
this as kind of like an inverted
backwards kind of inside out batch job
it's highly consistent
the thing is how are we going to
actually program this right
um we need a good way to program time
that thing about doing the thing in the
future uh as far as I know HTTP doesn't
do this right I do not know a way of
sending an HTTP request now and having
arrive in the week's time
um system.timer system.threading.timer
yes that would work until your process
crashes right and then you've lost your
system.training.timer so you've seen
something a bit more persistent so I'm
going to introduce now this notion of a
saga
um I'm not going to go into too much
detail about what the Saga is if you do
want to know more about that um have a
look at this URL uh take a photo with
your phone or whatever that goes into it
in great detail
what I'll quickly say is that Saga
there's Saga in this context was coined
in the 80s it was a way of breaking up
big transactions into smaller ones and
having a long-running process with some
states
um it was initially kind of more about
rolling things back so it's almost like
you do one part of a process you do the
next part you do the next part if
something fails you kind of like roll
each part back consistently
the real world doesn't tend to work like
that
um normally your business people will
say well don't just roll back the whole
thing and give the person that money
back do something else we'll find
another way or send an alternate product
we'll send them a voucher we'll do
something else so it's more about when
you find a problem you find another path
to get to do what you're trying to do
and ultimately which is to get the
customers money
so putting it very simply a saga is a
thing that receives lots of messages
it receives the first message
store some kind of state receives a
second message and what it does with the
second message depends on what happened
in the first message right that's really
a song in a nutshell and obviously that
state that it stores in between is
whatever it needs from the first message
so if you want to see that in more
detail do follow that
now how can we actually do that how does
that apply to this well if you look at
this that's actually what we're doing
right we're getting one message
we're storing the total and then when we
get the second message it depends on
what was in the first message right the
first message may be in an order for 110
pounds
in that case when we saw when we handle
the second message to submit an order
we're going to Discount that order by 10
right so it's a very very obvious use
case for a saga
and what we do a week later also then
obviously depends on what happened in
the first message right because we are
we are taking that week total that we've
stored and we are mutating it to take
away that order in a week's time
so how do we code this right so let's
have a look at some code because it's a
bit abstract I know that people like to
see code it helps them understand these
Concepts so
this is a saga right and a saga
as implemented in the service bus is
just a class right it's just nothing
other than a c-sharp class
I'm calling it discounting because
that's kind of the purpose here
and the first thing we need to do is to
think about that state so what I've done
here is
defined a nested class called
discounting data which is going to hold
our state I know some people don't
really like nested classes I'm kind of I
find I'm a bit icky myself but for this
case I actually quite like it I think
it's a nice way of expressing that this
is very very private state to this Saga
encapsulates this and it's only for the
use of this Saga so I think for this use
case the nested class kind of kind of
works fairly well but it doesn't have to
be nested you can just Define it
anywhere
what we do here is we inherit from this
Base Class this contains I think I
should say contains or is it contain
it is indeed contained this is just a
base class which gives us some things
like the ID of The Saga
um who sent the original message the
original message ID it's not interesting
to us right now just to show you what
that is it's just an infrastructure
thing it's very useful for some things
but uh not so interesting for us right
now
and other than that it's just a c-shock
classes and properties we're defining a
customer ID because we want to do
discounting per customer so obviously we
need to know which customer we're doing
the discounting for and then we've got
our magical week total right which is
the thing we're really interested in
I'm using a double just to keep the demo
simple you probably wouldn't do that in
production you probably use a money type
or something like that
then once we've got that class for the
uh for the state we can then Define we
can then say that this is a saga by by
inheriting from this Saga Base Class and
we say that the the this type parameter
here is the state that it holds so Saga
of type discounting data
then we need to handle obviously our
submit order message and we want to be
started by a submit order message and
incidentally this doesn't just mean
started by it means I'm started by a
submit order message and I handle all
the ones that come after that as well
and that gives us a method to implement
called handle if you've seen an end
service bus Handler before this is
exactly the same
um all we're doing here is handling that
submit order message
and submit what a message just looks
like that it's got an ID for what it's
worth it's got customer ID it's got a
total of the order it'll have other
stuff on it as well right I'm just
leaving it out for whatever two
um then we get this context object
that's just an infrastructure thing that
you can use to send messages out and do
other things I'll show you that in a
second
now to look at to work out a discount as
I said in the previous in one of the
previous slides it's very very easy
right we just look at this one thing
this week total right so when when this
method gets called the state has already
been loaded and it's on this data
property of the base class and then
we've got our week total right so
working at discount level very very very
easy indeed
once we've got that discount level we
then send out another message to process
the order and we've got the order ID on
there we've got the discount level we'll
have other stuff as well right I'm just
leaving it out for brevity
then we add this week's uh this met this
orders total to our week total right so
we call it for next time next time we
get an order
and then comes the magic part
we request a timeout
we pass through this is a method on the
base Saga class we pass through this
context subject I mentioned before
because that's just required we say
seven days from now right in a week's
time and we just pass along the original
message we could pass along anything
here but I may as well just pass along
the same message again because it's got
that total on there that we need because
that's what we need to take away in a
week's time
then we need to say that we handle
timeouts
of types of mid order right as well as
handling the original submit order we
handle timeouts of that type as well
that gives us timeout method to
implement
for one reason or another that's called
State I don't know if that's an accident
of history but that's the that's the
name of the thing we get in and we've as
you've seen we're sending that same
message through so it is a submit order
message we get the context object if we
need it we don't need it this time and
then we do something dead simple exactly
what I said before we take away that
order's total from the week total
all right and we're done
uh and then we've got our async tax here
I don't know if anyone loves async or
not it's uh it's a little bit kind of
above sometimes and yeah then we're done
I hope that makes sense more or less
um
it's fairly simple code as you can see
right it's not rocket science fairly
easy to look at and understand
um what's interesting now I think is to
show you what happens actually in the
back end so what happens in the at the
kind of infrastructure level so let's
switch back to our
slides
where are we
here yeah I'm showing you the code right
so let's see what actually happens when
we do this
what I've got here is a bus abstraction
which you can kind of think about as the
thing that kind of like looks at the
queue and we've got
um a persistor and a persistor is really
kind of an abstraction over a database
right and these are components that
n-service bus provides
when the message is delivered the bus
realizes that a saga handles this
message and it loads that Saga from the
database right loads of states in the
database and dispatches that message
into the Saga by calling the handle
method
then we do what we just saw in the
previous slide in the in the code The
Saga does that work and it requests this
timeout
the bus now does one of two things it
either and this is the preferred method
it either tells the queuing system which
uh how long to delay that message for so
it just says to the cooling system
deliver me this message in one week the
only queuing system that we support
other than we've seen which supports
this fully is azure service bus so Azure
service bus we can just say give me back
this message in a week as a service bus
instantly is just a queuing system right
just part of its name it's very low
level so it really is just a queuing
system rather than what we we refer to
as a bus
uh Amazon sqs kind of does it I'll come
on to that in a second rabbitmq you can
kind of make it do it a bit more than
that in a second as well if the queuing
system doesn't support delays at all
like Azure storage queues doesn't um
msmq doesn't although we don't really
encourage msmq anymore because it's
actually going to have support now
um we use SQL Server as a queuing system
that's got a natural mechanism for doing
this either so in that case we put the
timeout into the database right we have
to record the fact that this timeout is
due in the database and
we persist The Saga data at the same
time regardless of which delay method we
use and that will go to the database and
then we pull if if the timeouts in the
database we pull the database to find
out when the timeout's due that's not
nice right we don't like polling the
database so we always prefer using the
native queuing system instead and
letting that do the work for us so I did
say that Amazon sqs kind of does it
Amazon sqs lets you delay a message for
up to 15 minutes right so 900 seconds if
you want to delay a message for 600
seconds you're fine right you just put
it in time as an sqs to say give me
about this in 600 seconds and it will do
so
if you want the 2800 second delay a
little bit more difficult you can put it
in the queue for 900 seconds at a
maximum what we've figured out is well
we can just put a header on that message
to say when we get that back we still
need to put it in the queue for another
1000 hours of seconds right so we get it
back put it in the queue for 900 right
ahead for a 1900 right ahead of 100 put
it through 100 it's done it for us right
it's put the message through the key
unfortunately we have to hop off the
queue and back on again one two three
times extra but it's doing the work for
us so we prefer that
rabbit and queue is a bit more
interesting
um
rabbit and Q has this notion of time to
live
what that means is for a given Q
and rabbit mq you can say messages in
this queue live for
60 Seconds
after 60 seconds transfer them to this
other queue
and what we can do is not subscribe to
the original queue subscribe to the
other queue and by putting it into the
first queue we have a delay of 60
Seconds
see how that works and that works pretty
well so you can put it in a queue with a
600 second delay you can put it in a
queue with 900 second delay you can put
another q which is a 1500 and so forth
and so forth but you might be spotting
the problem here you have to create a
separate queue for each delay level
and
sometimes one might be enough sometimes
four might be enough sometimes you might
have a lot more and the thing is that
the API is very very flexible I can
basically write whatever I like into
here right I can have thousands of
different delay levels if I want to I
can be really evil right and write
random.next
and multiply it by something you know
whatever
um and the last thing we want is people
saying to us why isn't server but
service bus creating 10 000 cues in my
broker and so well because you've got
too many different delay levels use less
okay I think it might look for another
solution
um so we do need a better solution to
this right because the API says you can
delay for any time of length length of
time you want so let's take a simple
example 42 seconds we love the number
42.
uh but we know that the number 42 is
only written in that way with the digits
four and two in a certain counting
system right a certain number system
called decimal right or base 10 right
that's how we write 42 seconds
but we are computer programmers so we
know there are other ways of writing
numbers we know about this binary system
we can write this number as one hundred
and one thousand ten seconds in binary
so what we can perhaps do is create a
queue for 32 seconds a key for 16 a q
for eight a key for four two and one and
we can take our number 42 in decimal we
can write that in binaries 1010
alongside those queues
and then
if we put it through the 32 second queue
skip the 16 put it through the eight
skip the four pull it through the two
skip the one
we've just simulated a 42 second delay
right 32 plus 8 plus 2. so we think
that's we we like this solution we've
not seen anyone else do this right we
kind of came up with this and thought
this this might actually work
um it's a nice kind of fusion of basic
computer science you know binary and a
natural real world applications it works
pretty well
um we actually use headers again to do
this so you can put a header with the
binary number into rabbit mq and you can
tell rabbit and Q I think we do it via
regex we actually cite the rabbit and
queue look at the binary number and if
it's if that one's one put it in that
queue if that one's one put it in that
queue et cetera Etc
so it works pretty well
uh we can't delays messages for that
long with these cues I mean if you've
got these what is it six cues the
maximum delays uh what is it 63 seconds
um not that useful so we actually have
28 cues
that gives us a maximum possible layer
of 2 to 28 seconds or that many seconds
or about eight and a half years
which I think is enough for anyone
um why did we go with 28 well
we first thought 25 because that will
give us just over a year and no one
really thinks much in terms of more than
a year in business
um 25 is odd so it's 26 is even so let's
go for that and we thought well we think
that's enough let's just go one order of
magnitude higher it's only one extra Q
let's go to 27 and we thought no that's
odd let's make it 28 because that's even
so we ended up on we ended up on 28.
um we were really tempted to go for 32
right we lost 32 but that would give us
a maximum possible delay of 136 years uh
it I mean it'd be nice if someone's
using a service bus in 136 years but
it's a bit of a stretch of the
imagination but if anyone wants more
than eight and a half years We'll add a
29th
and probably add a 30th to make it even
you know whatever but it's more than
enough for now
um but you might be thinking well that's
all fine right we've figured out how we
can do this and this nice consistent way
but don't we just have the same problem
all over again right isn't someone just
going to press the button at the same
time
right and they're both going to see the
sum of 90 for the week total of 90. well
yes I mean I haven't stopped people from
clicking the button at the same time by
introducing sagas in the background
right it's gonna happen but remember
that we are now looking at a single Row
in the database right a single row with
customer ID week total
databases are exceedingly good at
guaranteeing transactionality around a
single row
but even with that what you have to make
sure of is that if we look at this code
what we're doing here is we are
retrieving that single row here and we
are writing back that single row there
right you only all you're doing is
adding things to property here but in
the background when you persist that
gets written into the database as that
single row
we do not want that to happen and
succeed without that bit there
succeeding right we do not want to send
out the message to discount if we fail
to write the week total back because of
concurrency because that means another
order's done that at the same time we're
using them on discount level potentially
right so all these three things have to
either fail or they all have to succeed
right we want transactionality around
the state of the Saga and sending
messages out of the Saga to do work
right because those messages are only
valid if that state is valid
so we need to wrap that in some kind of
transaction
now how we do this what actually happens
at runtime is we have these two sagas we
have these two users clicking at the
same time so what happens is those
messages may get handled at the same
time right we do we do default to
multi-threading right so two messages
can be handled at the same time by two
instances in memory of the same Saga
they both have their handle methods
called all that stuff happens that we've
seen in the code and then they try and
write The Saga data down into the
database right and the database as we
said is very good at guaranteeing
transactionary transactionality around
the single row it will allow one of them
to go in
the messages will be sent from that one
and that one will succeed
here things will fail and the messages
will not be sent
then what happens is that message will
go back to the queue essentially that's
a failed message handling scenario it'll
go back to the queue it will get retried
which and service bus does for you but
otherwise you have to write that
yourself it will get dispatched into
another instance of The Saga and memory
and this time it will read the state
that was written by the other message
and it will try and write back the news
week total and the messages will be sent
and it will succeed
how do we actually do that how do we
actually guarantee that transactionality
well
for some queuing systems and some
databases you can just wrap the whole
thing in the distributed transaction
right so if you're using something like
msmq and SQL Server you can wrap those
things into simple transaction and
Microsoft's infrastructure takes care of
that for you like I said we don't really
encourage msmq anymore because Microsoft
don't really support it anymore
um so really that's a kind of
Disappearing scenario we need something
else
this is how we do it in and service bus
using the outbox pattern this is another
entire talk in itself
if you want to know about that do follow
this URL have a look at the outbox it
describes an excruciating detail it
involves writing something to the
database and then trying to figure out
if messages has been dispatched it's
every time I re I actually actually
wrote a lot of this article but I still
have to go back and kind of remind
myself how does it work again but it's
been in production for ages and ages and
ages and a lot of systems and it does
work so we use this outbox to guarantee
that transactionality between queuing
systems databases which don't naturally
have it right it's very very important
that that's consistent
and the great thing is that these sagas
live in that code they live in your nice
DDD tdd you know whatever your
methodology you're using it sits
alongside the rest of your code it's not
some batch job that's plugged in on the
other side it is actually something that
lives in your code and it's highly
testable
we actually provide a we actually
provide a testable
message Handler context in another
package so when you're unit testing you
can pass that in you can you can pass in
a whole load of messages and then you
can look at that context and see what
messages were sent out
right so they're very very highly
testable
so we're on the way to killing the batch
job if you want to see more about that
do go to this blog post best of the
batch job we are on a particular
software kind of on a on a little bit of
a mission to try and kill the batch job
because we've seen it use so
inappropriately in so many circumstances
where other methods are much more useful
but
you may have you maybe you may be
thinking that that the scenario I've
just escrow I've just described okay yes
we can remove the batch job in favor of
something else in that scenario but you
might be thinking well I have this other
scenario in my system where a batch job
is just totally the right answer this
totally makes sense to be a batch job
and one of the areas I've seen this in
my career is in is in reports right has
anyone work here with a system which
produces any kind of report anything
yeah that's that's actually probably
about 80 of you so I've worked in
systems which have produced overnight
reports and
they've they've sometimes I mean this is
a good indicator right if you're doing
really well business is booming you're
getting loads of orders these reports
are getting more and more expensive to
produce that's good in a way but I've
been in situations where it runs
overnight and starts to finish around
lunchtime the next day
and it's kind of pretty I see a few
nodding head see I see other people have
seen this and and it starts to creep
right and I remember we we kind of like
had a side bet on how long it's going to
be before it takes until the end of the
next day for the batch job to run and
you know it was uh it was a bit it was
it was pretty scary because the business
were finding them it's a very difficult
to actually do their jobs getting the
reports that late
um another course you open an office in
Singapore and you open an office in New
York and San Francisco and you don't
have any night anymore so it's kind of a
bit of a problem
but the thing is reports are interesting
because they tend to be required at a
certain time during the day so let's
take a let's take a banking scenario for
example
the user might say well okay here's my
requirement I need a report at 9 30
every day of
all the transactions in the last week of
a certain size I want to see the
customers against those transactions
group them by custom for me that would
be useful and I want to see in which
location they are I want to see in which
country they are
and and you say okay that's interesting
what are you going to do with that
information by the way uh is that well
I'm going to look through them and if I
see three large transactions in a
high-risk country for a given customer
I'm going to tell my manager and start a
fraud investigation because we think
that's like a little bit dodgy
that is not a requirement
that is a workaround
they know that we store the transactions
in the database right the account
transactions and I know that if they
look at them they can figure out using
the data in there if there's possible
fraud
but the actual requirement is
if there are three large transactions in
a high-risk country for a given customer
in the last week I want to know about it
that's the requirement right forget
about how the system currently works in
your knowledge of it give me the
requirement
that allows us to do other things we can
go in and say well I'm going to do some
kind of automated pattern matching
right I'm going to when I'm going to
create a saga and when that Saga
receives a transaction occurred event or
something or some kind of message
I'm going to look at that and I'm going
to say first of all
is this a large transaction right
remember that thing I said about
ubiquitous language
starting to get enriched again you've
just learned there's such a thing as a
large transaction right like more than
ten thousand pounds or something
I'm going to look at high risk countries
right again you've learned there's this
thing called high-risk country you can
actually now see highest country as a
variable name in your code right you're
you're getting deeper insight into the
business problem here
I want to know if there's been three of
them in the last week
so similar to what we did before
we can receive a transaction occurred
message we can say is it high risk and
then is it large and in the highest
country yes add it to my current
possible fraudulent transactions
collection
right on my Saga state
send myself a message in a week's time
to remove
that transaction from my current
possible fraudid in transactions
and in exactly the same way as a week
total we've created the sliding window
of for the current week what is the
collection of current possible
fraudulent transactions right anytime I
receive one of those messages
if I've already got two of them
and this one is also a large transaction
in the highest country I've got three
right alarm Bell email the user
if you tell the user and they get a
notification they go to their manager
and imagine this is like and this is
kind of mind-blowing right because it's
real time business information right you
say to the manager
yeah I've got high risk I've got a high
risk situation here I think we need to
investigate some fraud here and the
managers assessed to you but hang on a
minute hang on it's six it's 4 30 in the
afternoon you get that report at 9 30.
why the hell is it taking you seven
hours to tell me about this this is
ridiculous like step up your game here
and say no no no this transaction
occurred in the last two minutes and say
what
but hang on a minute how do we know and
said oh yeah assistant told me it's like
yeah you know that you know that Saga
thing the developers were talking about
a few weeks ago yeah they implemented
that they they released a new version of
the system and that just tells us and
this is mind-blowing the manager is like
oh my God so we've got real-time
business information here right and so
well how do I okay I want more of these
sagas how do I get them right where do I
sign up
and what you have What's Happening Here
is this is actually translating into
real this actually does translate into
real business value right this is money
we're talking about here we are now
reacting real time right we've prevented
a possible 24 hours of possible for for
different transactions right you're
turning them to a profit center right
your system is turning into a profit
Center by adding this real-time
information
so I'm coming towards the end now and
I've actually raced through that but I'm
sure you're going to be happy to get to
lunch a little bit early
um if you want to know more about
long-running processes uh sagas uh
stateful message handling that kind of
thing I've actually prepared a set of
videos for you here so if you follow
this URL uh ndc-london batch
go.poticular.net do take a photo of that
um that's a set of videos by our company
CEO a guy called Udi Dahan who you may
have heard of it's actually a five-day
course that he runs and I just prepared
a extract from that so that's completely
free go and register go and have a look
there and grab your free videos
uh I hope you've enjoyed this um what
I've tried to do here is show you a
program model which Embraces time a
program model which allows you to enrich
your it encourages you to enrich your
ubiquitous language if you're into DDD I
said that so sagas are actually uh if
you're interested you've heard of
aggregate roots so a saga is actually a
very good aggregate route right in fact
it's actually just a very good object if
you've ever read anything by Alan Kaye
who talks about object-oriented
programming in the early days he never
talked about polymorphism and
inheritance and that kind of stuff what
he actually talked about was an object
being something that receives a message
encapsulates State and business logic
and send a message out right that's the
essence of what he described as an
object so sagas are actually very very
good objects
anyone here into tdd
and all that tdd that's probably
slightly less than half of you tdd tends
to be one of those kind of love hate
things I bet the people who didn't put
their hands up hate it
I've kind of like swung between between
the two kind of opinions a little bit
myself during my career
I think one of the problems with tdd is
that we don't often have very good units
to test
but a saga is actually a very very very
good unit to test right I can just show
you I've got some time left so I can
actually show you
um that test
uh framework that I told you about
um I've got a test
here right so what I'm doing here is I'm
just I've written a test called 10
discount
uh I'm creating let's just get rid of
this oops
let's get rid of that
so
I'm basically simulating a new saga so
I'm saying I'm going to create a new
saga class because remember it's just a
just a class right I can just create one
I do need to pass the the current state
into it which is just a new discounting
data right with nothing in it so
everything's going to be initialized to
zero
I then grab I then take four submit
order messages
and of course I'm emitting properties
and things like that which was which
would normally exist
one for 60 one for 60 another one with
10 other for 20. then I create this
testable message Handler context
and this is the thing we apply we Supply
as a special testing
harness for sagas
I can call my handle method with a first
order passing that context in and then I
can look at sent messages
right so I can see within that handle
method that the context was passed into
what messages were sent from within that
handle method and obviously I want a
discount level of zero
for that first message for that first
order
because the current discount that
current week total is zero
now the week total should be 60 right
because the total of that first order
was 60.
when I receive the second message
which is again a 60 I should still have
a discount of zero right so the discount
should have been uh zero for that second
order the week total is now 120.
when I receive the third order
I want to have a discount of 10
because the current week total is
greater than 100 right it's 120.
the wheat total is now 130 but we're
going to pretend that a week has passed
since order one
so we're going to handle a timeout of
order one
and now we we should see the week total
drop by 60 down to 70. we handle the
fourth order and we should have a
we should have a discount of zero
right
and we can look at the we can look at
the data and things like that to make
sure other things happening but this is
just this is showing you how to test
that one aspect of this counting level
being correct and you and this is a very
simple example you can have sagas which
handle
many different types of messages and the
the logic inside this handle methods is
much more complex but you can kind of
test you can actually write good unit
tests against all of this and I do
recommend this right I do recommend
testing sagas especially with the aspect
of time because you don't want to be
kind of writing a test which lasts a
week right you want a nice way to
simulate that and you don't really want
to have to like sit
um Advance the system clock and stuff
like that it's much nicer if you can
just pretend in your code a week's past
I would just say timeouts there
so let's switch back to the slides
yes so
uh as we've seen a lot of these problems
do root from being given workarounds
instead of requirements so do try and
push past those workarounds and look to
the actual requirements if you see if
you if you hear someone telling you how
a requirement in terms of how the system
works that's an alarm Bell right you
want to be able to talk to The Domain
experts who can kind of like release
themselves from that business analysts
are sometimes a bit of a problem with
that because they're kind of like um
some people call them proxy domain
experts or things like that they kind of
tend to have one leg in the system on
one leg in the business and they can't
help themselves but think about how the
business works when they're trying to
interpret a business requirement so just
watch out for that right try and get
past those workarounds talk to the
business try and get requirements in
pure business terms forgetting about how
the system works right because that's
your job you're the best people you're
the people that best place to figure out
how a system can make that business
requirement happen
um it kind of does stem from some
organizational problems you know a lot
of organ a lot of problems we do have as
developers are organizational and
they're not actually that often often
that technical so it's just something to
watch out for but that's another talk in
itself
uh we've gone through that very quickly
so does anyone have any questions here
because we've got 10 minutes left so
we're going to maybe a couple of minutes
if anyone's got any questions yeah
what if you go for a weekly discount
you have to actually rerun your build a
battery which will run and we compute
all the cycles and in that there's some
trade-offs comparing to initial approach
where you do compute
place of course you still have this
concurrency problem but as you said
yourself you have database which are
extremely good in solving control
problem so so what do you think about
like if that becomes a trade-off that
rules uh really sort of organization
wants to have rules changeable in that
sense right okay so I'll try and I'll
try and sort of paraphrase your question
into saying that we've looked at an
example where we have this discounting
thing in a week total which is very easy
to think about but this this the the the
thing that you're seeing is possibly
problematic is this fixed weak window
and the business might come along and
say and it's a very good question
actually the business might come along
and say yeah that thing we're doing for
a week we want to extend that to two
weeks
now in that case you you do have to take
some action some initial action to
change two two weeks the thing is that
your timeouts are still going to be in
there right they're still going to be
being delivered in a week's time but
what you can do is this comes down to
versioning you can erase a new version
of your Saga which just ignores the week
timeouts right it just ignores those
original messages because ultimately
they're just messages that are going to
sit there and we don't need them anymore
right but you will have to do some kind
of initial migration to say well we're
now going to set up we're going to look
at the orders but the thing is it's it's
a it's a release time thing it's not a
it's not a runtime thing so as part of
the deployment of that new version yes
it will involve a migration right so I'm
not saying this is a way of getting rid
of data migrations it isn't and that's
going to be required in some cases if
you turns out that things are going to
be a lot more flexible and kind of
levels of discounts are changing for a
customer depending on other factors as
they go through a lifetime you're going
to have to do something more complicated
um
this isn't a golden Hammer right it's
not a silver bullet so for those
complicated situations you may have to
look to something else but it's a good
point I think it depends on the level of
variability and sometimes and actually
this is a good thing to to talk about
if anyone's here if anyone who is
involved in a sometimes startup or
anything like that you don't really know
what your business rules are yet right
so doing things like this is can be
quite expensive right because you have
to you have to do in the invest in
modeling and looking at things correctly
if you're in a kind of startup situation
and you're starting to find out what the
best way to do things is and what the
best way to retain customers is just
write any old code because you come when
you discover what your business is
you're probably going to rewrite it
anyway
right so don't invest too much of that
and then in the early Discovery parts of
your business this is very good for much
more stable business rules which have
evolved through a stable mature business
that knows how things are going to work
but you know even still you can have
varying degrees of level of change I
hope that kind of answers the question
the sort of thing we could talk about
for for hours potentially
anyone else yes
infrastructure
and standard information
okay
so monthly Finance reporting possibly
like monthly invoice sending and things
like that well the interesting thing is
about that is um
the monthly invoice sending in
particular is very interesting because I
I wonder why the business is sending
monthly invoices at a certain set period
why isn't it sending an invoice at the
time the order is made dynamically as
the orders come in
it sounds like something that's been
designed within the constraints of the
current system
so it's almost like a backdrop is almost
self-serving in that scenario I mean
obviously there's more context I'm
probably missing
but
mm-hmm
oh so our other accounting parties might
might expect something at a certain time
of the month
um that's interesting you could
potentially when an order comes in send
a message to send this invoice on a
specific day obviously you're going to
get like a like a kind of like crunch of
messages coming at the same time on that
date to say send you know a whole load
of different invoices
um so that might that might be
problematic obviously if your if your
system is at such a stage where you've
got so many of these customers which is
good right you've got loads of business
that you you're finding it incredibly
difficult to make your system send out
all those invoices on that one day
um
this is a trap that's very easy to fall
into don't necessarily try and solve
that technically speak to the business
so you know we've got our business has
grown ten thousand percent in the last
couple of years we've got so many
invoices sent out in a month can you not
talk to the customers and say can you be
a bit flexible about this put half of
them in the middle of the month and I'll
say yeah sure we can work that out don't
assume that that's a fixed thing talk to
the business right because so much can
be can be sold by talking to the
business and working out something
different
this is also a very good General thing
to always bear in mind
but if you want to talk about that more
please come and grab me after
so how are we doing for time uh yeah
we're a few minutes before lunch so I'll
let you go now so you can get to the
head of that queue I hope you've enjoyed
that do come and grab me if you've seen
me ask me about the stuff
thank you very much
[Applause]